a federal judge says stormy Daniels
lawyer cannot question President Trump
under oath about her agreements not to
mention that she allegedly had sex with
mr. Trump in 2006 the judge ruled the
request for a presidential deposition is
premature at this point in the case
Paula reads at the White House Paula
good morning good morning this is
certainly a victory for the president
but this case is not over yet the judge
is essentially saying that Daniels
lawyers were just moving too fast the
judge points out that the president and
his team they haven't even had a chance
to formally respond to these accusations
about that hundred and thirty thousand
dollar payment Cohen made to Daniel's
and without that formal response the
judge says look it's it's too early to
even talk about compelling the president
to be deposed but the next goal for the
president and his team is try to force
this case into private arbitration
rather than letting it play out in
federal court where everything is public
but a vanetti he sees reason to be
optimistic he says the order does quote
not bode well for the defendants and he
suggested the court will ultimately side
with stormy Daniels with his clients now
her team wants a trial as soon as this
summer but Cohen's attorney calls this
decision sound and says that he believes
that the judges future decisions will
also favor the president Nora
all right Paula thank you so much